This video contains spoilers for the final
season of Game of Thrones - but according
to critics the show isn't just spoiled already,
it's become downright rancid.
Yes, the latest episode of Game of Thrones
has been getting the worst reviews in the
show's eight season history, as fans and critics
alike have banded together to condemn the
decision to have fan-favorite Daenerys Targaryen
suddenly go completely mental and murder tens
of thousands of people for no good reason.
Titled "The Bells," the fifth episode of season
8 has a dire 47% fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
That's several percentage points lower than
the previous worst-reviewed episode, "Unbowed,
Unbent, and Unbroken" from way back in season
5.
And it's just the latest blow in the show's
relentless descent into disappointment.
Every episode so far this season has had worse
reviews than the previous episode, dropping
from 92% for the season premiere... to 88%
for episode 2...
75% for episode 3... and 57% for episode 4.
How bad is it?
The season as a whole currently sits at 71%
fresh, which sounds decent until you realize
that the lowest total rating for any of the
previous seven seasons was 91% for the very
first season.
And those are just the critics.
Fans have been even harsher, giving this season
just a 43% rating so far.
Ouch!
Critics didn't pull any punches in their reviews,
with much of the disdain aimed at the showrunners.
Maureen Ryan of the Hollywood Reporter wrote
that she was shouting "don't do it!" at the
TV screen.
"I wasn't talking to Daenerys.
I was shouting at the writers and architects
of Game of Thrones, executive producers David
Benioff and D.B. Weiss.
But they did it.
They not only gave Daenerys the least-earned
character turn in the show's history - maybe
in television history - they rubbed our faces
in this colossal mistake for what felt like
an eternity.
To say the show befouled the bed in its penultimate
episode, 'The Bells,' is putting it mildly."
She continued,
"'The Bells' was Game of Thrones at its worst,
and it did untold damage to the show as a
whole.
It's going to be hard to think of the show
without feeling nauseated by what it did - especially
to its women - in the home stretch.
[...] Inescapably, infuriatingly, what we're
left with is apparently the central message
of Game of Thrones: B------ are crazy."
Anna Leszkiewicz of New Statesman agreed.
"'She went mad' feels like a lazy, stereotypical,
unearned plot device and one that was truly
horrible to watch.
At times, the massacre felt like pointless,
gratuitous audience torture … It feels like
Game of Thrones is throwing a major character
under the bus for the sake of an easy ending."
Akhil Arora of Gadgets360 had similar thoughts:
"Despite having some of the most well-acted
moments and epic scenes in its roster, Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 5 ultimately felt
hollow.
This used to be a show where major points
of a character's arc were laid atop on seasons
of foundation.
But in its most pressing hour, Benioff and
Weiss have largely thrown all that out of
the window in service of shock and moving
onto the next story beat."
And The Daily Beast's Melissa Leon wrote,
"The Mother of Dragons becoming a 'Mad Queen'
may work on paper with what the show has foreshadowed
for seasons all this talk of Targaryens' hereditary
madness, and her own streak of cruelty with
her enemies but her split-second decision
to systematically murder half a city of innocent
people does not."
Vulture's Kathryn VanArendonk drove the point
home, writing
"Disheartened isn’t even the right word.
I am exhausted by Mad Queen Dany [...] The
notion that this sprawling story about epic
political gamesmanship, the corruption of
power, the things we inherit from our families,
the people we choose to love, and the inevitable
inescapable march of death would ultimately
hinge on a trope as painfully stale as 'and
then the scary powerful woman goes crazy'
is, to be frank, boring."
NPR's Glen Weldon was more succinct:
"Dany got a raw deal.
Narratively speaking, Game of Thrones did
the Mother of Dragons dirty."
So can the show redeem itself in the series
finale?
After what happened in "The Bells," it's hard
to see how.
As the BBC's Hugh Montgomery wrote,
"By the end of this 90 minutes, as the ash
settled, it is difficult not to feel one was
looking at the charred remains of an era-defining
television show's integrity."
"Dracarys."
Rest in peace, Game of Thrones.
Rest in peace.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.